hello my devilish darlings it is I
Leonora Levay your hostess of horror and
I'm here to warn you that some viewers
may find tonight's programme disturbing
there will be discussion of transphobic
slurs and violence and graphic displays
of anime oh so if that's gonna make you
sad please don't watch this unless you
enjoy sadness I know I do but I'm a cop
mother wants you to take care of
yourself so here I made you a wet pot of
hot tea and you can take it out in the
balcony and pour it on some pedestrians
that always cheers me up
one Traps
[Music]
gentlemen of the Academy it is my duty
to submit to you the findings of my
latest mimetic research many sleepless
nights have I lingered in all the great
libraries of Europe scrutinizing volumes
ancient and modern in search of the
answer to two fundamental questions what
are traps and be they gay with respect
to the former inquiry I adduce for your
consideration
a treatise for the ladies scholar known
as the pedantic romantic we're in the
derivation of the word trap is traced to
patrons of animated pictures from the
Orient curious the chronicle begins in
the first years of the present century
when devotees of picture forums would
proclaim the idiom it's a trap alongside
the likeness of one Admiral Ackbar to
suggest that some manner of deception
had taken place contemporaneous to this
was a most whimsical mania for
depictions of nymph a chaplain asks to
some of which the aforementioned slogan
would be rejoined the implication
the subject of the portrait was not insu
the daughter of Eve but rather that the
spectator had fallen prey to some manner
of transvestite skulduggery furthermore
it appears that from the first the
designation trap has signified not only
transvestites
but transsexuals as well and this must
needs be remarked for his evidence such
persons of times and flame the last of
ordinary men it is hence with respect to
this phenomenon I pose my second
question thus fellows is it gay I'm
sorry who are you talking to
gentlemen of the Academy did you get
thrown out of Dairy Queen again it must
needs be remarked please stop breaking
into my house I shall be a queen of
Dairy I'm sure you will be crossdresser
hi I'm Nathalie when biological woman
can we pan the camera down my hair is
less hi our traps gay the meme that will
not die originating around 15 years ago
on 4chan the word trap refers to either
a male crossdresser or a trans woman
especially in a context of jnanis kawaii
decadence the meme our traps gay is a
mostly jokey debate about the sexuality
of men attracted to dick girls futanari
MTF you know a lot of these men don't
know or care but the difference between
a trans woman and a crossdresser so it's
kind of pointless to get hung up on that
the man peaked in popularity about a
year ago when someone released the worst
specimens of the white race into the
wild all traps gay one of life's most
important questions are traps traps are
gay you know yes
will there will there be transsexuals in
the Ethne state hopefully not to the men
who meme about this topic it's all
light-hearted fun it's part of a wider
game they like to play called is it
you know is it gay to have an MMF
threesome only if the balls touch don't
cross the streams and so on but too many
trans women the meme and the word trap
itself are highly offensive in fact last
year when I first proposed making a
video about this topic many trans people
on Twitter were outraged because they
felt that this topic is just too harmful
to even discuss so here's the challenge
I face making this video on the one hand
there's people who are going to be upset
and offended that I'm making a video
about this topic at all and on the other
hand there are people who think this is
all just harmless otaku should posting
and who are going to be annoyed by my
trigger warnings but first to the people
who think it's too offensive here's what
I have to say for myself I've always
believed that if you want to persuade
anyone it helps to meet them where
they're on and in this case our traps
gay is where people are on that one of
my youtube meetups I met a high school
teacher who told me that he overheard
some of his male students joking in the
hallway about our craps game when those
teenage boys go home and Google our
craps gay who do you want to explain it
to them
your choices are Miley innopolis this
guy a Scottish hate crime convict named
count dank EULA or this Tran and at the
risk of sounding arrogant I think it
should be me you know as trans women we
have little influence in society the
people who lead the conversations about
us are bigger and stronger than we are
so we're like a jogger racing against a
car the only way to win is to hijack the
car and so this video is my attempt to
hijack the conversation that straight
men are having about us as always my
aspiration is to derive a will
conclusion from edgy premises to
shitpost my way to the moral high ground
now straight men isn't all this offense
taking just more politically correct
cuckold redesigned to take away your
free speech well I assure you there will
be no taking of your free speech on this
channel unless you clock my makeup
dickbag comment deleted but if you want
to know why trans women are offended by
our crops gay
I'm happy to tell you not to silence you
of course but just in case you have the
intellectual curiosity to want to know
why someone different from you might be
hurt by something that seems harmless to
you so well let's put it this way to
transpannic the 1990 documentary Paris
is burning depicts the ball culture of
black and Latino acts gay and
transgender people in New York City in
the late 1980s one of the main
storylines follows a trans woman named
Venus Xtravaganza who describes her
precarious existence as a sex worker I
was with a guy and he was playing with
Mike cities until he touched me down
there he felt it he seen and he like
totally flipped out he said you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're a freak you're a victim of
AIDS and you're trying to give me AIDS
what are you crazy you're a homo I
should kill him and like I was really
terrified so I just jumped out the
window during the filming of Paris is
burning Venus was choked to death
presumably by a client her body was
discovered four days later under a hotel
pad trans women in my country almost
entirely trans women of color are
murdered at a disgracefully high rate
reaching a record of 29 deaths and 2017
the men who murdered trans women often
claimed they were provoked to violence
by the alleged deception of their
victims this is what's called the trans
panic defense when legally invoked as in
the 2004 trial of the killers of the
teenage trans girl Gwen Araujo one of
the killers who had sex with Gwen before
learning she was trans cried I can't be
[ __ ] gay before beating her to death
men are often willing to side with these
killers saying that if trans women don't
want to get murdered then they shouldn't
trick men but what you have to
understand is first men usually do know
when they're having sex with a trans
woman like if you have a dick it's
pretty hard actually do you have sex
with someone and have them not notice it
and second a lot of men view trans
women's entire existence as itself a
kind of trickery a black trans woman
named Ilan nettles was murdered
Haarlem in 2013 by a man whose friends
had mocked him for flirting with her all
she did to provoke him was walk down the
street with two friends the common
thread here is not deception on the part
of the victims but rather the drive of
the killer's to protect their social
standing as masculine and straight but
being perceived as a kind of fraudulent
lure is something that many trans women
across class and raised experienced some
version of because men view femininity
itself as a kind of enticement as the
orchid Asia's invitation to a proboscis
I was just reading a Twitter thread by a
trans woman who was attacked recently by
a man at her bar who started flirting
with her until he realizes she was trans
and then punched her like what was she
supposed to do to stop that from
happening just stay at home for trans
women fears about men retaliating
against us for existing actually limit
our freedom there's bars I won't go into
because I don't trust the clientele to
side with me if some [ __ ] like that goes
down and I've had little scares I was in
the back of an uber once the driver
comes on a little flirty you know what's
your name are you a student and I'm
thinking wow he thinks I'm young enough
to be a student but at some point he
goes silent and suddenly I'm getting a
very icy glare in the rear view mirror
like [ __ ] clocked and for a second
I'm like [ __ ] I'm gonna die in the back
of this car and of course I didn't die
the rest of the ride was quiet but it
was fine
I mean I'm gonna be fine because white
middle-class transsexuals don't get
murdered in this country the murder
issue exists at a specific intersection
of gender class and race and it's really
not my oppression to claim you know I
sometimes hear white bougie middle class
computer program or trans women be like
we're getting murdered in the streets
who's we it's not white middle-class
trans women so the transpannic murder
issue is really not my lane it exists at
this intersection of masculinity and
race and it's really not a conversation
that should be led by a white woman
especially when there's so so so many
things to critique about white
masculinity let's talk about some now
three taking offense
okay back to traps now this is my lane
I'm not sure anything has ever been more
my lane ah the exquisite pleasure of
being entitled to the soapbox so boys
I've showed you how trans women's
freedom is abridged by our need to
navigate around men who you are gender
presentation and start our very
existence as a kind of trap I think it
should therefore be pretty clear why
trans women are not the biggest fans of
you using that word for us or for
futanari or cross dressers or whatever I
mean to be honest if someone calls me a
trap my response is more like Wow a
transfer thought I look like a woman
but that's because I'm so pathetic I
have to go dumpster diving for
validation but the rest of the trans
women out there the ones with dignity
and self-respect you should definitely
not call them drops of course some trans
women will overstate the case and say
the word trap is literally getting trans
women killed which I can't find any
examples of the word trap being
connected to a murder but why don't we
stop using the word before someone dies
hmm because what you're doing when you
call trans women traps is you're showing
that you think of us the exact same way
as the men who try to justify attacking
us when a man kills a trans woman
literally the argument he trots out in
court is that he was trapped and that's
what you're reminding us of when you use
that a word
and that's why trans women are getting
triggered over you know sometimes people
have good reasons for being triggered by
things and this is one of those times so
if I were a different kind of creator I
could really end this video now I think
I've made a pretty convincing case that
trans women are justifiably offended by
the word trap but if I leave it at that
and this is for you Twitter this is why
I made this video if I simply argue that
our traps que is offensive then here's
what happens first a lot of people
simply don't give a [ __ ] in fact me
telling them it's offensive only
makes them want to say it more because
they feel in a deep level that they are
by nature superior to trans people so an
uppity to need telling them what words
they're allowed to say completely
embraces them so they'll comment traps
are gay well just to reaffirm their
superiority over me and that I have no
power or influence over them and there's
really nothing I can do about those
people but another group of people the
socially progressive liberals they'll
say ok so since you're offended by it I
won't say the word trapped anymore and
they'll be super woke about it and
they'll post Twitter call-outs canceling
anyone who uses the word trap and
they'll be very respectful and
compassionate toward trans people in
public so long as it makes them look
good to indulge and pity this tragic
third-world country of a gender minority
but then you'll go home at night and in
that twilight between consciousness and
sleep their inner voice will whisper but
our traps and then years later when
their son brings home a transgender
girlfriend will suddenly watch all that
shallow openness vanish like so much
politically correct a vapor real
acceptance has to be built and real
understanding so it's not enough for me
to argue that our traps gay is offensive
I also have to argue whether drops are
gay so our traps gay let's watch an
instructional video to learn more
[Music]
or a philosopher hello boys it is I the
half Queen points after 30 days and 30
nights the philosopher descended from
the mountaintop and to the gathered
villagers thus spake our traps gay and
he to whom the half Queen thus replied
hmm let's see let me think about it oh
I'm gonna stop saying trap now because
it's not a good word as has been
explained in fact it's really best to
treat it like a slur so what we're
really asking here is if a man is
attracted to or has sex with a trans
woman is that gay well the simple answer
is no because trans women are women and
a man having sex with a woman is let's
see here according to the experts I've
consulted it is not in fact gay but
that's not the most persuasive answer
because in order to find it convincing
you already have to believe that trans
women are women and unfortunately if you
ask the average person about this what
they say is something like sure I think
trans women are women but they shouldn't
expect men to want to date them unless
they're into that sort of thing
oh and what sort of thing is that
usually when a man tells you he's dating
a woman and you say oh what's she like
and he says she's from Cincinnati your
response is not oh David I didn't
realize you were into that sort of thing
in other words these people tell you
trans women are women but and then they
say something that shows they don't
really think trans women are women at
all
so since test audiences have proven
shaky on that point it would basically
be circular reasoning for me to try to
argue that attraction to trans women
isn't gay because trans women are women
since the womanhood of trans women is
precisely the point that's being
disputed
so maybe the observational approach is
better the facts are indisputable many
heterosexual men are attracted to trans
women and comparatively few gay men are
now to trans women
is just an obvious fact about our
everyday experience in the world we now
who's attracted to us and who isn't so
to us this completely unnecessary debate
it's as impractical as the question of
whether the Sun will rise tomorrow sure
philosophers can say but how do we know
the Sun will rise tomorrow to which the
correct response is shut the [ __ ] up
nerd stop playing 3d chess against your
own brain and find a real thing to worry
about it's just a basic fact of
experience that the Sun rises every
morning and to transwomen it's a basic
fact of experience of the people who are
attracted to us are people who are
attracted to women of this is man I've
been with since I started my transition
all identify is straight and all had
only ever been with six women until this
trio malong am I really so powerful as a
doctress that lifetime heterosexuals are
turning gay over these tiny tips let's
not get cocky I mean if a man is
attracted to women and not to men and he
perceives me as a woman and is attracted
to me as a woman and he sleeps with me
and then he continues being attracted to
women and not to men in what world is
that anything but a straight man what
wild maze of reasoning do you have to
invent argue that this man is really gay
well we all know exactly how this maze
of reasoning goes beginning with the
obvious what about the penis oh yes the
penis look baby we'll get to the penis
don't you worry about that but first I
should remind everyone that a lot of
trans women do in fact have vaginas
because they got filed
in fact I've been thinking of signing up
for a vagina myself but the thing is I
make too much money for Medicaid now so
I have to form an LLC become my own
employer so I can give myself health
benefits and AH has so much paperwork
you were to be going to unincorporated
legal entity in this country just
thinking a [ __ ] cut of course
transphobic radical feminists will say
it's not a real vagina just a [ __ ] hole
because the real vagina is a sacred
passage and that's fine by me what am I
gonna do with a sacred passage anyway
get fingered by the Pope pass straight
men don't get hung up on this I
guarantee you no straight man has ever
thought of a vagina as a sacred passage
they're either grossed out by it or
they're trying to climb inside what I'm
trying to say is in the past I've been a
little uncertain about getting a vagina
because my genital dysphoria is that bad
and besides chicks with dicks are very
in right now right 2019 very trending
and being a [ __ ] it's kind of like
being a legendary Pokemon you know
people take interests people pay
attention to you and isn't that what we
all want
but unfashionable though it is I do
think I want the surgery because well
guys kind of confess something kind of
dark to you I have this really [ __ ] up
fetish where I want a boy to put his
penis in my vagina
crazy right I mean I like anal but the
gross thing about anal is you have to
eat will you I don't want to eat well I
want to shove garbage into my mouth hole
and get dick does that a crime it has
kind of a scary surgery though like one
of my vagina sucks I'm afraid I have
some bad news
the tests are bought and were showing
them in the medical terminology your
vagina does indeed suck the point is the
easy sell version of the argument I'm
making is that there's nothing
homosexual of at a man's attraction to a
trans woman who's been on hormones a
couple years she has female skin she
smells like a woman she has breasts
she's giving hair body face she's
post-op and has a vagina no even in this
situation people will still say it's gay
because of the chromosomes but look
human beings have five senses and none
of them can detect chromosomes sexual
attraction is not based on some
chromosomal metaphysics of gender it's
based on perception and of your man and
you perceive someone as a woman and
you're attracted to her as a woman then
you are having a heterosexual moment my
dude
congratulations UUM breeder the argument
people make is okay fine it's straight
if you mistake her for a biological
woman but if you know she's a man and
you're still attracted then it's yeah so
look if you believe that trans women are
men the not belief might interfere with
your perceptions and it might change the
relationship between your perceptions
and your sexual response but more likely
is that you still will feel attraction
to the trans woman only if you value
your identity as a straight man
you'll feel ashamed of your attraction
you know try to fight and deny it and
you'll probably end up treating trans
women like absolute garbage now if I
wanted to make the SJW 101 type response
here I would say trans women are women
because they identify as women and so
every heterosexual man who's
experiencing attraction to a trans woman
is necessarily experiencing heterosexual
attraction because of the way the person
he's attracted to identifies but that's
just replacing the black and white
thinking of a biology dogma with the
black and white thinking of an identity
dogma but human sexuality is not black
and white it's not even shades of grey
it's a multicolored acid trip it's
centaur Donna Summer charging at you
with a spanking paddle so sexual
attraction is not based on chromosomes
but it's not usually based on
psychological identity either most of
the time initial attraction anyway is
based on what I'd call presentation
how're you looking at and I think that's
especially true of men they get turned
on by that initial visual pop they see
they concur they come I mean you have to
admire the simplicity of it sometimes I
wish I said look if what you want is a
woman who pumps then rest assured there
are plenty of trans women who pop maybe
you don't think I pop but you'd be
hard-pressed to argue that any number of
trans models and actresses don't pop as
much as any sis woman pops so the pop is
undeniable no one's questioning the pop
in fact without the pop it never would
have occurred to man to call trans women
traps because they wouldn't be trapped
if they weren't attracted in the first
place but a lot of men seem to think
that the pop the visual presentation of
a trans woman is some kind of illusion
or facade that at some point will be
dropped revealing that our womanhood
sham and that were really man now here's
a big difference between dating a trans
woman and dating a drag queen if you did
assist dry queen at some point you're
getting a man honey as explained by the
only good youtuber Jasmine masters I
don't want to date nobody who wouldn't
date me like this because this comes off
and you're not doing nothing with this
but if you date me there's no D dragging
there's no moment where I become a man
baby what you see is what you got at
least on this side this is my natural
side and this is my biological side
we're discussing people are trans we
immediately scan the first paragraph
trans woman in never purse them and
their biological pronouns biology
everyone's always hating on trans women
for being stereotypically feminine so
why do you think that in the bedroom
we'd be any other way part of it is that
people are really ignorant about hormone
replacement therapy and what it does for
trans women it feminized as our skin or
smell our body fat distribution and
makes us grow breasts that's right these
are my very real very biological titties
I mean I'm wearing a push-up bra but at
least there's something to push-up now
here I'll show you I mean they're small
but it's not by any measure a male chest
and what I have is very real very
biological and very female you people
think everything to do with trans women
is fake fake boys fake boobs fake hair
but that's prejudice more than
observation like I've noticed that
whether or not I actually wear a wig in
a video has exactly zero effect on how
many people comment to call me a man in
a wig so I may as well just wear wigs my
mates look at my boobs done too since
people are gonna call them fake either
way but for what it's worth this is my
real hair at least on this half and
these are my real boobs
and if I bring home a gentleman all that
stays on in bed and it's there when I
wake up in the morning but what about
the penis alright alright look if the
penis is feminine how is that gay I rest
my case
roll credits
[Applause]
[Music]
six the feminine penis look some guys
want the t's and the D and that's now a
lot of people assume that the
involvement of a dick even a lady dick
makes any sexual interaction with a man
gay but isn't male homosexuality usually
understood as attraction to men and not
merely two penises wherever they may
arise I think there probably are some
gay men who really just like dick and
I'm not judging I'm not here to attack
anyone's preferences but being a
straight man I don't really think that's
best understood as a man attracted to
vaginas you call women [ __ ] but then
you're always like yo periods I'm a
straight man I'm not used to putting a
towel down when I [ __ ] I don't know how
to use a condom because I expect this
room and it be on birth control and do
everything for me and then you have
straight in cells online calling Leah be
a roast-beef and generally putting on a
show of vaginal disgust I mean if you're
gonna date sis women are post-op trans
women I think you owe it to them to be a
little more of a Jain appositive because
even those straight men are like you
dicks that's gay you guys also kind of
love dicks you're always drawing them
your buildings look like dicks you're
poor and all has dicks in it so what
about dicks on chicks well men like
chicks and men like dicks so what's the
problem officer
I think the booming popularity of tea
girl porn speaks for itself on pornhub
the [ __ ] category contains more
videos than other such popular
categories as rough sex orgy and webcam
and it's mostly straight men who watch
it when a dull Empire dot-com moved
their tea girl content from their gay
site to their straight site views
increased 50% in 2016 the same year
North Carolina passed a transphobic and
discriminatory bathroom bill the adult
site game links top-selling titles in
North Carolina where my transsexual
teacher [ __ ] shenanigans and Joey
sill Vera's trans visions six a lot of
straight men first find out about trans
women through porn which isn't great
since most t girl porn is not trans
positive and uses dehumanizing slurs
like [ __ ] and [ __ ] which is how you
end up living in a country full of
people who will jerk off to you but
won't give you rights so to a lot of men
that's the representation we have she
emails [ __ ] and Caitlyn Jenner great
I love that for
now there probably are some men who will
always be put off by a woman's having a
dick and you know what that's fine not
every man can be a poet a visionary a
sage you like what you like I'm not here
to police anyone's desires in fact quite
the opposite I'm here to liberate men of
sophisticated taste from society's cruel
and unjust prejudice against their tea
girl loving ways the liberation begins
with understanding so who are the men
who love trans girls
well according to trans women I've
talked to in my own personal experience
the Meno datas can be divided into three
general groups Group one are men who to
be honest or actually kind of put off by
the dick but they're so attracted to the
woman it's attached to that they're
willing to work around it or wait for it
to grow on them group two are men who
are attracted to trans women including
their penises but they don't
specifically fetishize the penis so they
wouldn't mind if they're trans lover had
genital reassignment and got a vagina
and then group three or a man who
specifically fetishize chicks with dicks
and often want to worship the pain
answer be penetrated by it now Group
three or where the trans community calls
chasers stating chasers is generally a
bad idea because their attraction to us
is based around fetishizing or genitals
which is often the part of us that were
most uncomfortable with so if you're a t
girl who likes men and group two is
really Goldilocks perfection unless you
really like topping or you found the
surgery now I should say that group two
does include some bisexual men and
bisexual people of either gender can be
great partners if you're trans you like
girls you like dick I'm a girl with a
deck let's make this happen that said if
someone views that part of me as male
and wants me to do with it but man deal
with it
then pass not interested now you might
be wondering what is this postmodern
neo-marxist SJW insanity how can i view
it as anything other than a male part
it's a [ __ ] penis well I'm glad you
asked I always jump at the opportunity
to enlighten someone about the X disease
of the feminine penis you see there are
three factors that make a penis feminine
context usage and physiology so first
context picture and your mind's eye a
feminine woman now picture her with a
penis
that's not a man's penis that's a
woman's penis it's feminine because of
the context without it's in second usage
a lesson and penis etiquette it
gentlemen need not be coy about his
penis he may flaunt he may brandish he
may he may penetrate he may order you to
get on your knees like a good girl
whereas it is a truth universally
acknowledged that a lady of good
breeding never brandishes her penis when
she rises from the bath she covers it
gracefully with a demure hand
and when not in use she keeps it
carefully stowed away here's how to tuck
your penis like a lady the first step is
to put on a set of vicious stiletto
claws this doesn't make things any
easier but it does build character next
you want to take not one but two pairs
of cotton lined poly spandex bikini cut
panties at least one size too small and
pull them most of the way up your legs
now there's just no way to put this
delicately my dears
you're gonna take your claw and you're
gonna grab your scrotum and you're gonna
yank that bubblegum back into your peach
crease now hold it back with one hand
and with your other hand push your penis
back pressing those little legs up into
your pelvis bring your thighs together
to hold everything in place and then
pull your panties up front first then
back run your hand over it to make sure
nothing's seeping out the sides and then
voila it's like it was never there for
more information you can purchase my
book talk your penis with a new foreword
by dr. Jordan Pete Peterson
I've never explained but the context and
the usage of the feminine penis so let
us now turn to physiology most people
don't realize that taking feminizing
hormones actually changes the anatomy
and functionality of the genitals
shrinking everything down and softening
everything up that means changes to a
little thing not a lot of people are
talking about but something I've been
trying to raise awareness of you know
start a conversation open a dialogue
really get people talking about 7 the
mouthfeel
oh hi it's me Natalie when you're
tasting specialist I have tasted
everything the Royal Flush oral sex girl
deck boy dick girl [ __ ]
and let us not forget about the
masculine clitoris but today we amuse
the palate with the feminine penis now
with respect to flavor the feminine
penis has more sweetness in the
masculine penis and fewer truffle mousse
while retaining the fundamental dick
umami with respect to mouthfeel the
feminine penis is of course softer and
smoother than the masculine penis and
does not become as urgent and as for the
common taste well it is a known fact
that girl come is clear liquid and
tastes of saline
whereas boy come is milky viscous and
more acidic it is therefore the
consensus among sommeliers that sucking
a female penis is not gay Cheers
[Music]
eight being straight is pretty good so
I've been trying to clear up some
misconceptions about sex with trans
women but ultimately you kind of just
need to try it yourself to fully
viscerally understand why sex through
the trans women is sex with a woman now
we must always be wary of being overly
simplistic and are thinking sexuality is
complicated and while it's undeniable
that many straight men are attracted to
trans women the messy reality is that a
lot of straight men are also attracted
to male Kroft stressors before I
transition I was a crossdresser and I
didn't present super womanly either like
fully doctor Frankenberger
and that's why I'm so iconic I showed
the world that in two years you can
transition from literally dr. Franken
for her to a very real very biological
drag queen but even when I was that
baritone voice transvestite
I still got semi regular messages from
Matt and being like though I'm a
straight man but I'm like really
attracted to you and you trust as a
woman and it's really making me question
my sexuality now I could flatter myself
with some kind of retcon and be like
well maybe those men just picked up am i
inherently womanly female energy
innocence that I've always had since I
was born a female and biological soul
trapped in the body of a cross-dressing
baby but let's be real there are
straight men have thought of cross
dressers they're straight men who [ __ ]
drag queens there are straight
identifying men who [ __ ] other straight
identifying men what is going on here
straight man what is your deal who are
you what is your life
how does she become straight do they
recruit you were you grilled I blame the
parents let's go back to the game you
guys like to play the one I call is this
gay the commonly understood definition
of homosexual acts is that their sex
acts between people of the same gender
but I've heard men argue that if a woman
puts on a strap-on and takes a guy then
that's gay or that it's gay if a man
enjoys a woman touching his nipples to
be clear we're talking about one man and
one woman Eve sucking Adam's nipples and
according to these men it's totally gay
with that shoes is that the idea of
heterosexuality includes much more than
just sex between a man and a woman it
actually encompasses a complex series of
rituals that must be performed by people
who have claimed the correct roles so if
a man deviates from his assigned part
and he approved bedroom activities then
according to this very fragile view of
heterosexuality he ceases to be strange
even a man's own relationship with his
body is policed by these narrow confines
for instance some men won't even wash
their own [ __ ] for fear that some
involuntary twinge of anal pleasure
might transform them irrevocably into
raving homos I mean to be fair before I
washed my [ __ ] I was a quarterback
now I'm a cheerleader
Vict ry don't tell the coach I was a guy
this obsession with the details of what
sex is allowed and what prohibited
reminds me of what psychologist Jonathan
Hite calls an ethics of purity and
degradation basically it's a style of
neural thinking that treats the body
like a temple if I must be protected
from desecration which means you have to
obey laws about how you can [ __ ] and
what you can eat so for example
religious dietary laws
I think this hyper-masculine hetero man
code is basically an ethics of purity a
kind of kosher law governing
straightness and the is this gay game is
his theology now this whole line of
thinking has been reduced to absurdity
pretty effectively by of all people
count thank you law if you class
yourself as a straight man I'm Jill
masturbating that means that you're
touching a deck and that's key
well memed my lord where it means the
pinnacle of the whole conversation is
reached when Dan Keeler concludes that
since a woman inherits half her DNA from
her father she's technically half a man
and therefore having sex with a woman
it's pretty gay obviously this is
shitposting but it's logically just as
good an argument as traps are gay
because chromosomes so I think what we
have here is a very bad theory about
what it is to be gay so what is being
gay Socrates on second thought I don't
know her 9 being gay is good actually
sometimes when you've been arguing about
something for more than half an hour
it's good to take a step back and ask
yourself why are we even asking this
question in the first place why does it
even matter whether attraction
gay or straight it seems like the most
pressing reason is that a lot of men
equates straightness with manhood and
they defend their manhood at all costs
now men this might be difficult to hear
and maybe you don't want to hear it from
me but this idea of manhood is hurting
you and it's hurting since women and
it's hurting trans women and it's
hurting gay people for one thing it
makes you really really bad at sex who
wants to sleep with a guy who is so hung
up on homophobic paranoia that he can't
even enjoy his own body having your
nipples sucked does not make you gay
being pegged does not make you gay
sucking another man's dick just to try
it does not make you gay and why because
being gay is a socially constructed
identity defined as a type of person
who's persistently attracted to people
of the same gender
if you're persistently attracted to
people of the same gender and you
identify with the word gay then you're
gay if not then you're not and nothing
you can do will change that so that's
one reason to stop worrying about this
and reason to is that being gay is good
actually I mean why would you be worried
about this if you didn't think being gay
was bad now I don't identify as gay
except in some pan LGBT cultural sense
we the gay but as a queer person I can't
help but be a little bit wounded by the
fact that straight men are so obsessed
with proving that they aren't like us
but that is not a wound I'm going to
dwell on because life is much too short
for me to waste any more time processing
your homophobic baggage or traps gay
baby who cares just to it feels good
that's the simple answer but the truth
is that when people say craps are gay
but there's nothing wrong with being gay
that is nothing but a sneaky attempt to
call trans women men and to reinforce
the stigma against dating us among the
group of people who are in fact most
attracted to us because it is mostly
straight men and not gay men who like us
in the gay stigma is the reason why only
a small fraction of the men who were
attracted to us are willing to openly
date us and the stigma is very real a
straight man who date's a trans woman
takes on some of the burden of queerness
men who date us can be mocked
other men they can be rejected by their
families they experience and short a
sample of the difficulty all queer
people face but a real man in my opinion
is not the kind of man who lets other
people's prejudices control his life a
real man does not act like an insecure
little boy afraid of what people will
say about him
a real man owns what he likes and is not
ashamed of the women he loves and so my
edgy little boys by that measure I may
be a woman but I'm still more of man
than you
ten I have feelings too well I guess
today we learned that our traps gay is
not a debate worth winning because just
by participating we're accepting the
validity of an innocence e'er question
and the bigoted assumptions that relies
on now some harsh words have been said
about men tonight and I think that
harshness is deserved hashtag not all
gamers but also this video completely
centers men's feelings and I have
feelings too god damn it and some of
those feelings are not all that
different from the anxieties men have
let me explain let me explain
so I identify my sexuality as queer and
poly which in my case is politically
correct terminology for confused [ __ ]
before I transitioned I dated women and
I still do have less specious and less
bonaga feelings but early on my
transition I encountered a lot of turf
[ __ ] and it really scared me off dating
sis lesbians which I never have even
before I transitioned the question do I
want to [ __ ] men have been in the back
of my head for a long time but about a
year ago I was like
[Music]
how to [ __ ] men but when I first started
messing around with men I mean I was
terrified because men are scary and in
my early transition I'd only dated
bisexual trans people and enemies and as
an aside some of those experiences were
really revelatory a person with a vagina
can be fully a man in bed that teaches
you something about gender and might be
harder to learn otherwise
and loving a trans woman like I still
sometimes do struggle to fully believe
that I'm a real woman but to experience
another trans woman not just as a woman
but as like the radiant model of
womanhood that's an experience that's
meant a lot to me and if you're
attracted to women and that's an
experience you haven't had you're
missing out but what I was gonna say is
bisexual trans and non-binary people are
a pretty safe group of people to date
when you're early in transition because
they're pretty chill about anatomy and
presentation but if you're gonna date
says headmen you need to be serving
women and I guess I don't need to but it
doesn't hurt and I did wonder if I was
woman enough for it so the first couple
of times I was so afraid I was like when
I take my clothes off is he gonna think
I'm a man basically my anxiety was our
crops gay but what I ended up doing is
just working up to things gradually and
of course you start by sucking dick
that's very safe because like what
red-blooded man is gonna turn down a
t-girl [ __ ] and it doesn't involve my
junk in any way then I got a little
bolder and I got with a guy who like
years before I transitioned we'd been
guy friends so to then have a sexual
experience where it was very much
between a man and a woman like that [ __ ]
is super hot recently I took what seemed
like the biggest risk and I let a
straight guy go down on me
so nervous about that because like what
if he thinks I'm a man what if he's
repulsed can you feel like a woman while
your dick is being sucked the answer is
yes it was so hot I loved it he loved it
and just knowing that he'd never done
that before but I would say it's special
10 out of 10 and you know what he told
me after he told me he liked the
mouthfeel everyone's talking about it
now [ __ ] so look I really don't want
to shame men for being anxious about
dating trans women because I mean I was
anxious to in the other direction but I
do wanna shame man for treating trans
women like their dirty little secrets
and I do on a shame man for dehumanizing
us and voting away our rights my day
well jerking off to [ __ ] foreign by
night and I do wanna shame man for
refusing to date us because they're not
[ __ ] strong enough to shoulder one
hundredth of the burden of stigma that
every trans woman carries every moment
of every day and I do want a shame men
for attacking their trans girlfriends
because they couldn't stand being
treated like a gay man for five minutes
that is pathetic if you're so worried
about proving you're a man why don't you
start by standing up for the women you
love you [ __ ] cowards
so look what I'm asking for is so basic
don't call human beings traps if here
trying to trans women don't be ashamed
of it it's okay you can date us or more
than just jackoff material if you aren't
attracted to trans women respect the
people who are if you do date a trans
woman
treat her like a princess because God
knows she's been through enough [ __ ] and
finally protect trans women of color at
all costs
all we want here is basic human decency
is that really too much to ask well this
is the internet so yes yes it is god
damn it
well that was long
I suppose the lesson his as Sigmund
Freud once said sometimes a cigar is
just a beautiful woman's
[Music]